♪ ♪
>> Jesse: PRESIDENT JOE BIDEN
IS URGING TO TREAT FENTON ALL
OVERDOSE DEATHS THE SAME AS
COVID.
IT'S MADE IN CHINA AND SMUGGLED
INTO THIS MOTHER SOUTHERN BORDER
IT'S DEVASTATING OUR COUNTRY AND
FEELING IN LARGE PART A RECORD
HUNDRED THOUSAND AMERICANS DIED
FROM OVERDOSES LAST YEAR.
AN ORGANIZATION CALLED FAMILIES
AGAINST FENTON ALL IS ASKING THE
JOE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION TO
COUNT FENTON ALL POISONING THE
SAME WAY THAT ACCOUNTS COVID-19
DEATHS.
THEY CLAIMED THE DATA COULD HELP
MEDICAL OFFICIALS PINPOINT
HOT SPOTS AND SEARCH RESOURCES
TO SAVE LIVES.
AND THAT'S SOMETHING TO GET A
DEAL RIGHT?
>> Greg: YOU CAN DEFTLY SOLVE
A LOT OF THESE PROBLEMS BY JUST
WITH COMMON SENSE BUT THE
PROBLEM IS ALWAYS GOOD TO BE
DEMAND AND IF YOU CRIMINALIZE
THE SUBSTANCE THE MITT DEMAND
MOVE US TOWARDS THE CRIMINAL AND
A PERFECT WORLD THIS DRUG WOULD
NOT EXIST WHO WOULD NEED IT AND
HE COULDN'T GET IT ANYWHERE BUT
THE FACT IS PEOPLE MAKE OPIATES
IN THE CRIMINAL SUPPLY WILL
ALWAYS BE THERE WHICH IS WHY YOU
SHOULD BE USING RESTRICTIONS ON
THE PHARMACY IT JUST LIKE DURING
PROHIBITION IF YOU TAKE, IF YOU
BAN BOOZE THE STILLS HAVE THEIR
HAZARDS THEIR SLOGAN TO GET
DRUGS OF ITS ZAN AT SIX OR POT
ITS COUNTERFEIT AND IT'S FILLED
WITH VENTILATORY DON'T CALL IT
OVERDOSE WE CALL THE POISONING.
THE BEST THING IS THE EASE UP
RESTRICTIONS DON'T DRIVE PEOPLE
OUT OF THE STREET AND PERHAPS
START LEGALIZING IT I LOVE TO
SEE AN OTC AT SOME POINT BUT I'M
NOT HOLDING MY BREATH.
THE OTHER THING IS HE OF THE
TREATED LIKE MASS MURDER.
IT'S INTERESTING TO ME BECAUSE
IF YOU WANT TO TREAT IT LIKE
COVID WELL, IT CAME FROM CHINA
TOO IF YOU BRING THAT UP AS A
RACIST?
DID IT COME FROM CHINA AND WHEN
DONALD TRUMP HAD THE IDEA OF
BOMBING DRUG DEALERS IN MEXICO
AND EVERYBODY FREAKED OUT WHY?
THE TERRORISTS.
>> Jesse: NARCO TERRORIST.
ITS POLICY BECAUSE YOU WANT TO
SAVE LIVES IT'S GREAT POLITICS
TO FOCUS ON IT LIKE THIS.
>> Dana: BUT ALSO BECAUSE OF
THESE DEATHS IS ANOTHER MAJOR
BIPARTISAN ISSUE.
THIS IS NOT DISCRIMINATION OTHER
REPUBLICANS WERE DEMOCRATS THERE
HURTING EVERYONE AND THEN NBC
POLL THAT WE REFERENCED A COUPLE
OF TIMES EMIGRATION WAS STILL IN
THE TOP FIVE OF THE ISSUES THAT
MEANS THAT IT IS REALLY MUCH ON
PEOPLE'S MINDS AND PART OF THAT
IS THE DRUGS ARE COMING INTO THE
COUNTRY.
THE ADMINISTRATION HAS A WEEK TO
DECIDE ABOUT TITLE 42 WE 40 SEEN
THEM REPORTING INCREDIBLE WAVES
OF PEOPLE COMING ACROSS AND WE
KNOW FROM THE GOVERNMENTS OWN
DOCUMENTATION 18,000 MORE
CROSSINGS A DAY WHICH MEANS HOW
MANY GOT AWAY'S WILL THAT BE AND
HOW MANY DRUGS WILL BE COMING
ACROSS?
IF YOU WANT TO GALVANIZE THE
COUNTRY AGAINST SOMETHING LIKE
CHINA AND FENTON ALL IN FOUR
AMERICANS INTO THAT VERY EASILY
BUT THIS.
IT >> Jesse: AND BECAUSE IT IS
SO SMALL GERALDO AND WE CAN
BRING IT OVER IT'S VERY HARD TO
DETECT.
>> Geraldo: I THINK WHILE I
GENERALLY AGREE WITH DRAG ON THE
TREATMENT OF A LUCID DRUGS I
THINK THERE'S SOME AND CALLED
THE PROHIBITION MENTALITY.
AS YOU RESTRICTED SO THE DEMAND
GROWS.
HE ALSO GREG SAID SOMETHING THAT
WAS DIFFERENT THAT WAS IMPORTANT
THAT THE DISTINCTION BETWEEN
FENTON ALL AND DRUGS IS THAT
DRUG OVERDOSE AND THEN THERE WAS
A POISON.
IF THERE IS A POISONING THAT IS
A CRIME.
THAT IS A MANSLAUGHTER.
I BELIEVE THAT WHAT YOU HAVE TO
DO HERE IS TO TREAT THIS ROSE
170,000 OVERDOSES GOT THE POISON
FROM SOMEBODY.
NOT TALK ABOUT SOMEBODY WHO
POISONED THREE PEOPLE ON THE
BLOCK.
AT THE RETAIL LEVEL LET'S HAVE
SOME HIGH PROFILE PROSECUTIONS
IT'S A FEDERAL TASK FORCE YOUNG
AGGRESSIVE D.A.'S AND GO AFTER
THEM DON'T GO AGAINST THE CARTEL
WHICH IS UNOBTAINABLE RIGHT NOW.
GO FOR THE GUY ON CORNER.
GO FOR HIM AND WHACK HIM WITH A
MANSLAUGHTER INDICTMENT.
THE CIRCLE AROUND THE JUNKIE
KNOWS WHO GAVE HIM THE DOPE GAVE
HIM THE POISON IN THIS CASE.
THEY KNOW THAT IT WAS FREDDIE
MIKEY, OR SAMMY AND HIS
NOTORIOUS AND THEY SPIKING THE
COCAINE.
WHACK HIM WITH A MANSLAUGHTER
INDICTMENT AND LET'S SEE HOW
MANY OF THOSE CAN ALTER SOME
CONDUCT IF IT'S PROMOTED IN A
BIPARTISAN WAY WILL GO ONE AFTER
THEM THEY'LL STOP THE WAR ON
DRUGS IS THE WAR ON THE KILLERS.
AS THE MANSLAUGHTER IS.
>> Jesse: WOULD YOU BUY INTO
THAT ROUTE?
>> Judge Jeanine: I CERTAINLY
MANSLAUGHTER IS APPROPRIATE IN
TERMS OF MY CAREER I'M SURE
PROSECUTED MANSLAUGHTER OF
SOMEONE WHO GIVE SOMEBODY DRUGS
WHO THEY KNEW WERE DANGEROUS OR
THEY ARE THE PERSON WOULD
OVERDOSE THAT'S NOTHING NEW.
HOWEVER THIS IS THE DIFFERENCE.
[LAUGHS]
HERE'S THE DIFFERENCE.
WHEN YOU SAY YOU PROSECUTE THEM
FOR MAN SLAUGHTER THAT'S GREAT
BUT THAT'S NOT HOW I DID IT.
I WOULDN'T END UP WITH JUST A
LOCAL GUY I'D SQUEEZE HIM UNTIL
THERE WAS NOTHING LEFT TO
SQUEEZE.
FOR GOING UP THAT LADDER UNTIL
YOU GET THE BIG GUY.
UNDECLARED WAR BY CHINA AGAINST
UNITED STATES AND THE NUMBER ONE
AGE GROUP OF PEOPLE WHO ARE
DYING OF THESE FENTON ALL
POISONING OUT OVERDOSE POISONING
OUR MEN BETWEEN THE AGES OF
18-45.
IF YOU HAVE A WAR THING ABOUT
EVEN UKRAINE WHAT ARE THE AGES
OF MEN WHO END UP GOING TO WAR,
18-45.
THERE IS AN UNDECLARED WAR THAT
THEY DECLARED AGAINST US AND SO
I THINK THE BETTER IN YOUR IDEA
I'M SURE IS GOOD.
WE HAVE TO START RECOGNIZING
THAT IF YOU DON'T TAKE THEM DOWN
TITLE 42 BUT WE HAVE TO DO IS
RECOGNIZE THAT IT WILL BE THE
END OF CRIME THE WAY WE SEE IT
TODAY IT WILL FLOURISH OVER THE
NEXT DECADE OF THE END TITLE 42
BECAUSE THE CARTELS ARE LICKING
THEIR CHOPS THEY'RE GETTING
MONEY THERE MONEY LAUNDERING AND
THEY ARE INVADING THE
UNITED STATES.
>> Geraldo: I THINK OF TO MAKE
A DISTINCTION BETWEEN FENTON ALL
AND DRUGS.
>> Jesse: DON'T GO ANY